[Music]
hello friends we're so happy to be with
you again in this program i'd like to
know
today we have a very special guest with
us i'm sure you've seen him many times
here in our program
and our salva's worship services
pastor daniel gover from the fresno
central seventh-day adventist church
welcome pastor thank you it's i'm very
glad to be here thank you
um
we want to remind you that you can send
your questions
any questions that you might have in the
bible we will try to do our best to
answer those questions to the following
address tv at some tv.org
this is tv at some tv dot org
uh we promise that we will answer your
question
uh in the order that we received them so
before we begin
uh we need to pray we cannot open god's
word without prayer pastor
can you please pray for us let us pray
our father in heaven thank you so much
that you give us this privilege of
opening your word together thank you for
the bible thank you for the many many
men and women that throughout the ages
of christianity
have suffered and shed their blood so
that we would have the living word of
god with us today
i pray that your holy spirit may guide
us as we speak and may you be honored
and glorified and may everybody
listening be blessed we pray in the name
of jesus amen amen
amen
well we have
our first question for today
comes from jarriel aponte
and this question
is about
first john 3 20 and 21 i'm going to read
the entire question it says how to
differentiate between having a heart
that doesn't condemn you as first john 3
20 and 21 says
and having
a seared conscience
or a hardened heart
first timothy 4 2 in light of romans 2
14 and 16.
please explain these verses in order to
understand how can god judge fairly
are these passages suggesting that as
long as you be sincere you will get to
heaven regardless of watch of what or
who you put faith in
is this the way people who
have never heard the gospel can and will
be saved
it's a very good question yeah
what are your thoughts on that pastor
well first of all yes it's great
question thank you so much for saying
sending this question to secrets
unsealed
i say i think that the best thing we can
do when it comes to you know a question
that quotes several bible texts is
actually go to the texts
and read them and try to situate them a
little bit in their context and that's
going to allow us to think clearly about
this so first john chapter 3
verse 20 and 21
say
for if our heart condemns us
god is greater than our heart and knows
all things verse 21 beloved beloved if
our heart does not condemn us
we have confidence toward god
and i'm going to read verse 22 as well
and whatever we ask we receive from him
because we keep his commandments and we
do those things that are pleasing
in his sight
now
in order to situate even better i'm
going to read verse 18 and 19. it says
my little children let us not love in
word or in tongue
but in deed and in truth
by this we know that we are of the truth
and shall assure our hearts before him
so
i think it helps when we you know put
the the quote in the bible verses that
are quoted in its context so clearly
here you you see that john is talking to
a christian audience right and he's
saying
that we are trying to do what god wants
us to do we want to keep his
commandments he
talks about the commandments you know
verse 22.
and you know he talks about believing in
jesus a
and even for people who are trying to do
their best who love god who
pray who read their bibles even for us
that do those things and you know
we many times are
we have these these questions in our
mind
am i you know am i really doing
everything i should do am i okay and my
relationship with god
is everything as it should be you know
sometimes as human beings we have we go
through these questions
i think it would it's actually dangerous
if you feel that you know i've i'm okay
you know
so
uh i think it's it's a a blessing to
have this verse in the bible if our
heart condemns us even and when we're
trying to do the right thing even when
you know
we're following christ sometimes we fall
sometimes you know sometimes you think
about errors that you've done in the
past
so sometimes you feel condemned by your
own heart
but this text is reassuring us god is
greater than our heart and knows all
things
amen now the next verse will put that in
a context says beloved if our hearts if
our heart does not condemn us i believe
he's here speaking to people who are
walking
in all the light that they have
but being humble enough
to understand
that
they may they may be you know getting
some things wrong and you always need to
be humble to think that way you know
so i think you need to clearly
understand this text in that context
to then couple it if you want to put put
it close to first timothy chapter four
verse two which i think is addressing
people that are that are in a very
different page let's put it that way
yeah yeah um you're going to say
something i cut you off sorry yes no um
i think
know the context of first john 3 uh well
it's speaking about the law of god from
the beginning
yes and um
there is something that god has
given to each one of us and that is
conscience you know i i think i i think
hearts also could be referred here as to
our conscience our minds yes
and
i like verse 20
because not every time we feel condemned
means that we are really condemned
exactly
i like it because it says if our heart
condemns us god is greater than our
heart
in other words
not we should not always believe
our impressions but we should
bring them to god
who knows our hearts and who knows our
motivations he knows
if we suspect that we are having a wrong
motivation well god is greater than our
hearts and he knows exactly if uh we are
pure in our motives or not but then
verse 21 says but if our hearts does not
condemn us we have confidence toward god
now this can be dangerous
if we take it just like that right then
this can lead to self-righteousness
because i've heard people say you know i
don't feel bad about this right so it
means that it's good
what is the assurance that we have
to know that
if we don't feel bad about something
that is coming from god well verse 22 as
you mentioned
says
whatsoever we ask we receive from him in
other words there is assurance there is
confidence there
why because we keep his commandments and
do those things that are pleasing his
side so the commandments of god that
reveal the will of god when we
when we
expose our hearts to the searching of
god and in light of the law of god which
is the
standard of righteousness then we can
truly know whether
our hearts are condemning us or not yes
yes exactly and i agree fully
i like what you said that
you know sometimes we feel condemned but
that doesn't mean it's god condemning us
you know actually jesus is not in the
business of condemning he came to save
amen so the holy spirit does bring
conviction to our hearts many times
helping us to understand that we're
doing things that are not good and we
should repent but he always gives us
hope so
it is true that many times our own
fallen conditions and our our minds and
our hearts deceive us
and make us feel bad and many times it's
not god uh doing that at all
but now to read to the second passage
that he quotes here first timothy
chapter four verse two
i really think that if you start in
verse one read verse two even verse
three and four you clearly see the
context there's a very different context
than you have in first john chapter
three
for us first timothy 4 verse starting at
verse 1 now the spirit expressly says
that in the latter times some will
depart from the faith so you're talking
here about people who depart from the
faith
giving heed to deceiving spirits and
doctrines of demons
so this is very clear you have in first
john chapter three you have people who
are trying to do what is right they're
trying to love god love people in a very
practical way they're even trying to
keep the commandments of god and
sometimes they still feel in their
hearts that i don't know if i'm really
you know doing everything i should
because sometimes we're tempted to look
inside instead of looking at jesus so
but here it's different this is the here
it's talking about first timothy 4
talking about people who depart from the
faith
give heeds to deceiving spirits and
doctrines of demons
speak lies in hypocrisy
having their own conscience seared with
a hot iron
so it's clearly pointing uh
it's clearly talking about people who
are
just pointing their lives in the exact
opposite direction of what god wants
right
and uh it's it's very clear for me that
this is a different thing it says
forbidding to mary well the bible does
not forbid to marry commanding to
abstain from foods which god created to
be received with thanksgiving by those
who believe and know the truth god has
created certain foods for us to eat and
there's nothing wrong with eating what
god has created for us to eat there's
things that god created that we don't
eat god created
uh stones and we're not to eat stones
right so there's things that god created
are not food and the bible tells us what
god created for us to eat what he
allowed us to eat throughout the history
of humanity what is not for us to eat
the bible tells us that very clearly but
to say that you should not eat or what
god has created for us to eat
it's against the bible and then it says
for every creature of god is nothing
enough is good and nothing to be is to
be refused if it is received with
thanksgiving we're satisfied by the word
of god in prayer so
you're seeing here two different groups
of people
some people are actually saying things
that are against the bible they're
departing from the faith they're giving
heeds to spirits of demons
and those the bible says are having
their conscience seared with a hot iron
they're clearly walking in the in a path
that is destructive
and that it ultimately leads to the sin
against the holy spirit because you just
don't want to listen to god's voice
yeah i was just going to mention that
i see this as the sin
against the holy spirit but ask me
against the holy spirit
and i like that illustration seared with
a hot iron
i think of that i mean if you
put a hot iron on your skin
eventually it becomes insensible it just
kills all the nerves yes you cannot feel
anymore and that's what the sin against
the holy spirit is all about yeah you no
longer hear god's voice not because he
stops speaking to you but the heart has
become so hardened yes that we don't
hear his voice that is true that's a
very dangerous thing right so
clearly i think you have two groups of
people here mentioned and now coming to
romans chapter 2 which i love i
absolutely love
this passage and i i i think it's
so good that uh
yeti owl oh jadiel
uh
sent this question because it really is
interesting to think about these three
texts together and and see what they can
mean for our lives and for uh the
character of god and the judgment so
anyways um romans chapter 2 verses 14
through 16.
i before i read these i just want to
mention that
remember then when you read romans the
main thing that the apostle paul is
talking about is righteousness by faith
now verse 13 that many authors never
quote
is actually interesting it says for not
the hearers of the law are just in the
sight of god but the doers of the law
will be justified
meaning that whatever you
believe that paul is saying about
justification by faith
is not against obedience to the
commandments of god all right so true
justification by faith true faith in
christ leads to obedience right if we
believe in the words of revelation 14 12
that says here are here is the patience
of the saints here are those who keep
the commandments of god and have the
faith of jesus so justification by faith
allows you to be obedient to god it
enables you to be obedient to to god
by his grace now verse 14 says for when
gentiles
who do not have the law now this word
for you know
this is a translation from a greek word
that could say but you know it's just
connecting to the other sentence
when the gentiles who do not have the
law
by nature do the things in the law
these although not having the law are a
lot to themselves verse 15 who show the
work of the law written in their hearts
their conscience also bearing witness
and between themselves their thoughts
accusing or else excusing them
in the day when god will judge
the secrets of men by jesus christ
according to my gospel
now i think this is amazing that the
apostle paul is saying that we are
justified by faith that faith leads us
to obedience to god
um
what
what what can we think about people who
never heard the name of jesus christ so
they can't really have a conscient
uh uh informed faith in jesus because
they've never heard the name of jesus
christ and they've never heard the law
as we have access to the law of god and
the moral law and the moral commandments
so
what what can we say about those people
and how god will judge them well they
have a conscience that you are talking
about conscience right
and they hear the voice of the holy
spirit speaking to them and they can
obey or not
and god is going to judge them and every
human being according to the light
that they have
exactly so i do believe that many people
will be in heaven
who did the best they could
and it's up to god to judge not us
and they heard the voice of the holy
spirit they loved people they loved god
to the best of their ability
but they will learn in heaven that they
can be there because jesus shed their
blood for them amen right
yes
these verses are
an enlargement or an explanation this is
actually a parenthetical reference to
verse 12
because in verse 12 apostle paul says
for as many as have sinned without the
law
will also perish
without the law
some people say you know i better not
learn from god's word in order not to be
responsible right but those who sin
without the law will also perish without
the law well in this context it means
without the knowledge of the law
and as many as have sinned in the law
will be judged uh by the law but then
how are the others judged if they sin
without the law well there's a natural
law in our hearts even
like
the most ancient cultures and and
current indigenous cultures that we have
that do not know anything about the word
of god
all of them have certain
ethical principles
very common
and that differentiate between good and
bad yes
killing is something bad lying is
something bad right so
how do they know that they don't know
god's love well god has put a natural
law in their hearts and by that by that
law they will be judged yes yes god
definitely
works with every single human being
and i'm glad that god is the one that
will judge not me amen amen okay i think
we have well answered
that question hopefully um
again from jarriel we
are so happy to receive so many
questions from him
um i can tell you watch our program
jariel we sent you greetings
this question uh has to do with the
previous sales school
lesson that we just finished on the book
of deuteronomy
especially in regards to the
unconditionality
of god's love
his question is based on first john 4 19
where it says that we love him because
he first
loved us
[Music]
he asks isn't that a selfish and
self-centered love
first corinthians 13 describes an
unconditional genuine love and according
to this chapter
loving god is far far reaching the
standard if it is just based
upon his goodness and his love for us
would we still love him if he asked us
to do something that we deem cruel and
contrary to love
would we be capable to sacrifice our
isaac because he said so because we love
him would we be capable to slaughter men
women children animals because he said
so and because we love him
would we be capable of refusing to bow
before an idol even if the penalty of
refusing would be getting thrown into a
fiery furnace because he said so and
because we love him
would we love him even if he didn't love
us
because that's what he
love in the flesh does with us help me
unravel this this dilemma or dilemma
so
um
how can we help our brother
well thank you for this question amazing
question um
first of all i would just like to
point out very quickly that
we believe that the words of god in the
bible were inspired by god well the
authors were inspired by god helen white
has an interesting
has some interesting comments about
inspiration and books selected messages
i believe it's volume 1 pages 21
something like that
she says that
the authors are inspired not the words
themselves exactly this is very
interesting and very important we
believe that holy men of god like peter
wrote
spoke as they were moved along as they
were carried along as they were inspired
by the holy spirit
we believe the same thing about ellen
white we believe that ellen white was
filled with thoughts from god that she
received visions and dreams from god and
she wrote with her human
language
so if the bible is written with human
language even though it's inspired by
god inspiration is perfect but the
language is imperfect
if the writings of ellen white were also
inspired by god but they are written in
imperfect language we cannot assume that
everything written in every quarterly
lesson of the sabbath school is dictated
by god because not even the bible the
spirit of prophecy were dictated right
so
don't let any expression or question in
the quarterly
uh bother you or take away your peace
okay many times things are not expressed
in the best and the best way i'm a
pastor pastor miranda is a pastor we
preach the word of god to the best of
our ability but many times we leave the
pulpit saying ah i didn't say that quite
right right so that happens to all of us
so it could happen that
in the quarterly things were not
expressed the best way however
your question made me think as well of
course
it says how can we love god
unconditionally if we love him just
because he loved us now there's things
that are very clear in the bible and
those we don't need to wander and and
you we don't need to struggle with look
at first john chapter 4 same chapter
verse 10
and this is love
not that we loved god
but that he
left us
and sent his son to be the propitiation
for our sins amen now when god created
humanity he created us in his image and
likeness we had in us
this divine resemblance and we could
love god perfectly love one another we
had no sin we had the opportunity to
commit sin but we our tendency was not
for sin
after we have fallen into sin the bible
tells us in jeremiah chapter 17 that our
hearts are corrupt we have the
capability to love because we were
created in the image and likeness of god
but that is not our normal and natural
tendency
so how can how can we be saved well by
faith in christ god gives us a new heart
there's a new creation that takes place
but we should not think that we are
transformed like that and then we love
god perfectly forever that's not in the
bible we are transformed by beholding
christ we are transformed in a
relationship with christ that's why i
believe that here in 1st john chapter 4
is saying we love him because he first
loved us it's in that relationship where
god reveals to you more and more of his
love
and you become more and more in love
with christ
that you start loving god
loving people
loving what god loves
and eventually start hating what god
hates that's a a process that's a
relationship
of love with jesus
where you do your best and god is
working to will and and to do in you
right
because it's really all about
that
connection of love and of grace that he
has established with you through his son
so
um yeah i think we can point it that
direction yeah sure well
god
reveals it
or i would say love rebuilds itself
and
i'd like to put it in this way
love awakens love amen so it is not
self-centered love to say that we love
god because he first loved us
because we as sinners
can't love god it is impossible for us
to love god
without receiving
his love yes and how does he show us his
love
that is the most sacrificing way of
showing his love at the verse you read
verse 10
we know
we read it again we know in this this is
his love
for that we love god
not that we love god not that we love
god but that he loved us and sent his
son to be the propitiation for our sins
so that's the way he shows us his love
yes
and our love for him is a response yes
to what he has already done for us so
this is not a
self-centered love
now if he ask us to do anything
and we are sure that it is him asking us
then
we should
do it because we love him not by
obligation not thinking
that i will be saved
if i do it or not just thinking on the
reward yes
we're just do it because we love him yes
he whatever sacrifice he asked us to do
will never be compared to the sacrifice
of jesus on the cross yes
yes i i love the fact that the bible
says
god is love
it never says
human beings are love
right
it doesn't start with us the source of
life is god the source of love is god we
can only love like you said and i
completely agree we can only love
because
we receive that love of god
and we start loving him back now we were
created with the capacity to love
the bible does say that we are to love
god that we are to love people so human
beings can by god's grace
be restored to that love
but the truth is that it starts with him
amen though
we we can only do something right if we
are enabled by god the apostle paul said
um in a different talking in a different
context but it's the same thing even in
ministry everything we do should spring
out of love for god and for people he
says our capacity comes from god not
that we can think or do anything of
ourselves
so it's not a bad thing
that we recognize
that
it's all in him you know whatever i do
it's just
just a
a response to his great love and even
that response is enabled by the power
that he gives me amen
well
that was a very good
question and
we just prayed that we may receive the
love of god daily
without his love we can't do anything
his love is the source of our spiritual
life and it is the power that enables us
to keep his commandments thank you for
being with us in this program
see you next time
[Music]
you